ciao
bentornati solita storia ciao nuova
challenge più o meno slime questa volta
a youtube controllerà i nostri slime
abbiamo fatto niente controllati da sei
e da google
allora come funziona se avete visto il
mio video in cui si ri e google
controllare il miur flime capire che un
po come funziona in pratica noi andiamo
a cercare ora su youtube uno slide
dobbiamo scrivere le nostre iniziale può
iscrivere slime il primo slam che
compare dovremmo riprodurlo identico
quindi vince chi lo fa più di chi riesce
a farlo più somigliante allo slime
originale quindi potrebbe capitarci
qualche piccolo da ora andiamo subito a
vedere qual è il nostro l'iphone da
ridere lo stesso un sicuro la loro
bellissima generale le frenate allora
nei mini stralis dollari come secondo
nome a st
slime vediamo allora a fare un giant
grossi placed slime conosco questo tipo
di slide vediamo un po wow wow in una
sorta di grossi ok rischio fare per tom
cruise line scusate qual è questa senza
tipo il grigio che mi è riuscito con
viola il blu un milione di lanzi ok
quindi cordolo klein che dovrò fare io
ed è abbastanza difficile voglio da te o
con quello che dovrà fare
vediamo due canali che dovrà fare mi
tutti gpt
sono online vediamo un po che l'inter
lime
by b b sembra semplice evitiamo ma non
si vede niente
allora il primo slime utile che compare
in regola ma quello non si vedeva
abbiamo un mega butters lime allora il
model clay ce l'abbiamo
so bene migliaia pentirsi ea spezia
assolutamente che la sfida abbia inizio
e alla fine del video come sempre di
mettere il sondaggio dovrete votare se
ho vinto io se a vito vitale in base
alla somiglianza
adesso devo rivedere qui vedere
challenge che abbiamo fatto potete
vedere la consistono la prima volta da
circa o avanti del 57 per cento quello
lo so perché ma dipende da molte altre
persone hanno votato
notiamo un pari delle altre sale grazie
che iniziamo subito e proviamo a
riprodurre questi due primi mi piace una
sorpresa
abbiamo un cameraman volante vorrete due
splendide inquadrature e siamo subito a
cercare di produrre il nostro slider
minimo chi riesce a pirlo prima aula
allora io inizio con la colla bianca
quindi devo fare una sorta di grace
cicli grossi celestino tipo un po di
lozione io invece fatto subito a correre
ha subito uno stop è sporcato e mezzo
con il suo è un bel po perché secco
appunto tutorial della ragazza che
mettiamo col fondo siamo solo colorare
mettere un po di schiuma è che non è
così pazzi e butterfly me ma io sono
bravissimi
vedremo allora lì per prendere effettivo
metteva poche gocce di blu quindi devo
stare attenta a non mettermi troppo le
diamo così come diventa più bello questo
amore bellissimo e sarebbe nessuno che
stia colorato mondo ne aggiungo un po
era un po di colore anche quando mentre
la schiuma da barba quindi meglio farlo
più forte e poi dopo facciano gli altri
ingredienti che sia almeno sul sicuro di
un bel colore allora il mi sembra che
sembra parte il cielo meno suo spero che
non cambi avevamo ad aggiungere un po
d'acqua perché per fare il loft di click
no info e robson glossy glaze aggiunto
un bel po d'acqua
vediamo anche qui pianti matro colore
perché vuole un colore molto forte un
colore molto acceso e lo sto mischiando
perché lo voglio più acceso perché
questi colori su colorano tanto più le
cose
seconda cosa
pressione da barba clay perderà un po di
colore quindi è meglio avere piace il
problema per il gela è che il colore
potrebbe cambiare colore pazienti non in
giallo verde che disco è merda ti
mettevi con 20 reti in 37 verde tecnico
da parte della gente qualcosa si sta
spezzando un pochettino mostrando dei
dei pezzettini berti quasi toni metterlo
dall'inizio
aggiungo ancora un po di azione e io ho
tutto il corpo di colorante perché sta
diventando verde
[Musica]
il piccolo fronte più acceso ok perché
il colore rimangia più di ora procedo ad
attivarlo anch'io che a me chi vorrà un
bel po per attivarlo a meno che non
potevo chiamare un altro mi salverò
scrive deve rimanere un po più morbido
per noi è granché
bac domani quindi magari posso posso
aggiungere magari un po di burro ne ha
fatte un po di maistra dico per amido di
mais per renderlo figo vincerà questa
volta mi sento chiesto che riuscirò ma
tu pensi sempre di pizze ciclo però dici
perchè te importunato con la ruota
nella maggior parte degli a volte ho
questa volta decorati vanno perché c'è
un tacco di acqua quelli di 15 un sacco
di tempo non ti vario invece tu non sai
la lì pronta sì ma non voglio continuare
con siccome tu già quasi denso vi faccio
vedere qui è quasi aggiungerei un po di
fecola di di amido di mais per farlo più
bat ormai scorso anche perché questa
cosa qua e un po glossy quindi tutti
strand le rende così non so proprio
metterla bajofondo capitare ma deve
essere fatta
vediamo come diversa superyacht forze
forze possiamo buttare
non so perché ma sembra buono sembra un
accademia cuore io né primo pasticcera
tipo cosa dovrei fare
così dire niente
non so se aggiungere altro altro ambito
di mais o attivarlo tua sembra un posto
per torta ad est permesso lo mettiamo
dal forno come se permetti il premier
forno come succede condotte che
persisterà ma non inizia attivato
[Musica]
sperimentiamo se invece non solo questo
slang sto facendo io sia lo stadio bella
ciao è direttamente dentro nella
spazzatura di deo tutta l'emilia
ok ragazzi ci stiamo più o meno che
dobbiamo però mescolarlo un pochettino
però più o meno ci stiamo quindi ve li
facciamo vedere bene e poi li
paragoniamo a quelli del video profilo
da oltre che dei vicino entra in tanti
non carlo york miami all occhio ad un
pochettino di meano il mio sedere qui
attivato un pochettino di meno perché
poi dopo quando ad aggiungere il play
anzi io vado ad aggiungere proprio
adesso quindi dover siamo
proprio curioso di vedere come diventa
bellissimo nell'altra colore
innanzitutto l'ho preso dal terrore in
un po come di bello fatto volutamente lo
attivato volutamente un pochettino di
meno e la pizza con la lotta è una
nostra invece prevediamo e adesso
e adesso che vanno a girarlo mi rimarrà
tutto in formato nelle mani veniamo fa
[Musica]
da mischiano bene ma che devo vincere
non mi devo dire che stai facendo
chi erano calma di calder tempo sta
creando slime collanti magari lincoln
nato è piano piano troviamo tasso scende
carmen ha fatto una splendida viglio
tesoro si sta a casa dalla ma c'è ancora
un pochettino di che lei dentro che non
si è mischiato bene però sei facce di
wow sta tenendo proprio burroso
saperlo si chiama pronto così
ok allora può iniziare la sensazione
allora non mi ricordo adesso come dove
vado presentava nel video ora veniamo
anche le immagini dell'altro prima fanno
vedere bene allora fanno un vero batte
il claim valgono un vero butters line ed
al meglio credito questo sta tirando
sposa funziona dai disegni e batteri
però io mi sembra che il colore stia un
po sbiadito no come spedito è un po
sbiadito mi sembrano anzi fatto molto
per noi il coltello per fare un pochino
più giallo di consistenza affetto dai
uscito battuto bene date un voto da 1 a
10 per somiglianza nei commenti
latteri bellissimo iscritto ha fatto al
doppio di slime è tornato ora accade
tutto dal tavolo guarda è che pure mi
puzza è la sorella
basta basta tocca a me e poi vi metto
anche soltanto allora ecco fa il mio
slime
come potete vedere è uscito bello glossy
è un po poco gili il comune mi è
sembrato abbastanza simile è un pochino
che ci conto quindi il padre pochi
ingressi evento funziona ha detto il
passo meglio e molto grossi devo dire
molto bello una volta che fa che
vincitore anche sentiva molto vicino
dipende la santis torriglia
all'originale
allora andiamo ora a vedere l'originale
effettuiamo silenzio miglia allora
eccolo è un pochino diverso ma studio
lei voleva veramente
diciamo che più bello il colore cotico
il leader video però non è quello di dar
via sbagliato quindi saremo al momento
ci hai fatto visuale aspetta
no non puoi non mi piacciono agli sport
di tutte le mani così
no non puoi fare foto da una dozzina di
meta ma nei maiali aveva già terminato è
stato la presentazione dopo aver visto
il video e quindi rinnovo da te a me
comunque non è cambiata
per niente mi sembra che colora non è
quello prossimi sembra non sappiamo
quindi votate anche il film slime da 1 a
iscrivetevi i commenti quale mi piace di
più a quella digitale yo mostrato nostro
qui è perché lo shampoo ma il mio rossi
non si doveva qui dall'altro
che bello guardate com'è bello bat un
fatto il nostro invito allora
ora vi lascio qua il sondaggio è potete
votare chi ha vinto anita orbitale
favorita del tutto i due ladri sono
state buttate bloccate scriveteci nei
commenti che altre challenge come te che
facciamo assieme lasciato bella è che su
questo video e ora vi lasciamo basta
stelline se potete cliccare per vedere
la nostra challenge rivedete chi ha
vinto non è artificiale ed è andato a
contare quelle i nostri altri video
divertenti nel set l'antica quella che
proprio in tempo una visione